♪ [upbeat music plays]
Shane Shifflett: I work for The Bay Citizen.
I work a lot on the news applications,
so things like the Bike Accident Tracker,
the Census data.
Aurelio Tinio: So, this particular
infographic that we focused on
was about bike accident tracker.
It came about because one of
our beat reporters, Zusha Elinson,
who's focused on transportation,
got this data set from the San Francisco
Police Department,
which had detail on the various
accidents in the past two years
for the City of San Francisco.
And so, this particular use of
Google Maps and Google Fusion Tables
seemed like an easy way to get
something up as soon as possible.
And it provides an easy way to import
a KML file or different data sets
so that you can create maps,
different charts as well.
And so, as of right now, it's already
very integrated as part of our newsroom,
where other reporters are already
comfortable using it on a regular basis.
And it's a go to solution already.
Shane Shifflett: People can work
more autonomously.
It's a very easy to use tool.
And I mean it's pretty clear once
they start throwing data in there,
exactly what they can do with it.
And they can start slicing
and dicing and pulling it apart
and generating ideas for stories
that maybe it would take a long time
to get those sort of ideas moving
because you have to involve other people
and the staff or something like that.
So, it's really nice in terms of speed
and agility when you're reporting.
And then, in terms of just like
the technology aspect,
it's really nice to not be able to have
to support our own geospatial data sets
and work with configuring 'em and
optimizing 'em and so on and so forth.
Having Google host all that is just a huge
boon in terms of like productivity.
Aurelio Tinio: We're a limited company.
There's four of us developers and we do
look to other technology companies
to help put some innovation
into journalism.
And having a data application,
which was enabled by various technologies,
such as provided by Google,
is what makes my work possible.
Shane Shifflett: Just the same way
that photography
is another way of showing the emotion
that people experience
at important events,
showing data in a way that people
can look at it and really pull it apart
is another impactful way
of doing journalism.
00:02:14.833,00:00:00.000